[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to show favor to me you have told me
that most profound mystery concerning
the self by that this delusion of mine
is dispelled the origination and the
solution of all beings or Krishna as
issuing from you have been heard verily
by me at length as also your immutable
greatness
o supreme lord how you described
yourself even so are you I wish to see
your lordly form o supreme person if you
think O Lord that it can be seen by me
then Oh Lord of yoga reveal yourself to
me completely
the Lord said Behold my form so Arjuna
hundreds upon thousands manifold divine
varied in human shape
behold the adityas the vassals the Rudra
the to ash wins and the merits
behold o Arjuna many marvels never seen
before behold here o Arjuna the whole
universe with its mobile and immobile
things
centered in my body and whatever else
you desire to see but you will not be
able to see me with your own eye I give
you a divine eye behold my lordly yoga
having spoken no change to the Krishna
the great lord of yoga then revealed to
a Jana the Supreme Lord Li for with
innumerable mouths and eyes many
marvellous aspects many divine ornaments
and many divine weapons wearing
celestial Garland's and raiments
anointed with divine perfumes full of
all wonders resplendent boundless and
facing all directions if a thousand sons
were to rise that once in the sky the
resulting splendor may be like the
splendor of that mighty one there in
that form algernon beheld the whole
universe with its manifold divisions
gathered together in one single spot
within the body of the god of gods
then he arjuna overcome with amazement
his hair standing erect
bowed his head to the Lord and with
folded hands spoke I behold O Lord in
your body all the gods and all the
diverse hosts of beings Brahma Siva
arisen Brahma the seers and illustrious
snakes
with manifold arms stomachs mouths and
eyes I behold your infinite form all
sides I see no end no middle nor the
beginning two of you Oh Lord of the
universe oh you of universal form I
behold you as a mass of light shining
everywhere with the diadem mace and
discus hard to behold blazing like the
burning fire and the Sun and
immeasurable you are the imperishable
supreme one to be realized
you are the supreme substratum of this
universe you are immutable the guardian
of the eternal law I know we are the
supreme person who is everlasting I
behold us without beginning middle and
end your might is infinite you are
endowed with an endless number of arms
the Sun and Moon are your eyes your
mouth is emitting burning fire with your
own radiance you are warming the whole
universe
[Music]
you alone have pervaded the interspace
between heaven and earth and all the
quarters beholding your marvelous and
terrible form or Mahatma the three
worlds are greatly overwhelmed with fear
verily in to you the hosts of Davis in
turn summon fear extol you with clasped
hands crying hail the bands of great
seers and Siddhas praise you with
meaningful hymns and other nasty adityas
the versus the sadhyas the vishwas the
ash wins the merits and the mains and
the host of Gandharvas yakshas assured
us and said us all gaze upon you in
amazement beholding your great form with
many mouths and eyes with many arms
thighs and feet with many stomachs and
terrible with many teeth the world's
tremble and I to quake o mighty-armed
when I behold you touching the supreme
heaven shining multicolored with the
yawning mouths and large resplendent
eyes my inner being trembles in fear I
am unable to find support or peace or
Vishnu
viewing your mouths presenting are
generating fangs and looking like the
consuming fire of final destruction I
know not the quarter's of the globe nor
do I find repose be gracious to Lord of
the davis our abode of the universe all
these sons of Dada - that are together
with the hosts of monarchs Bhishma Drona
Khurana along with a leading warriors
and recite hastened to enter your
fearful mouths with terrible fans some
caught between the teeth are seen with
her heads crushed to powder as many
torrents of rivers flow towards the
ocean so do these heroes of the world of
men enter your flaming mouths as moths
rushed swiftly into a blazing fire to
the destruction so do these men swiftly
rush into your mouths to meet their
destruction devouring all the worlds on
every side of your flaming mouths you
lick them up your fiery rays filling the
whole universe with a radiance scorch it
or vision tell me who you are with this
terrible form salutation to you or
supreme God be gracious I desired to
know you the primal one I do not know
your activity the Lord said I am the
world destroying time manifesting myself
fully and have begun to destroy the
world's here even without you none of
the Warriors arrayed and the hostile
ranks shall survive therefore arise
bring glory conquering your foes enjoy a
prosperous Kingdom by me they had been
slain already you will be merely an
instrument to Arjuna you great poem and
slay Drona Bhishma yonder karna as well
as other mighty warriors who have been
doomed by me do not feel distressed
fight you shall conquer your rivals in
the bath
[Music]
you
[Music]